à compter de vendredi soir et jusqu'au
lundi matin un confinement sera
désormais adapter le week-end donc dès
ce week end la situation épidémique et
en particulier très inquiétante
alarmante même un habitant sur 100 dans
la ville tombe malade
chaque semaine duco vide à dunkerque et
dans la communauté de communes des
hautes flandre après nice c'est cette
fois dunkerque et sa région qui se
confie dès ce vendredi soir les
commerces non essentiels seront fermés
les déplacements interdit sauf motif
impérieux ou première nécessité même les
centres commerciaux de plus de 5000 m²
devront avoir recours au retrait en
magasin
par ailleurs dans l'ensemble du
département cette fois la vente d'alcool
à emporter ainsi que la consommation
d'alcool sur la voie publique sont
interdites
enfin le préfet continuera à mettre en
oeuvre des contrôles permettant de
vérifier que les déplacements
transfrontaliers sont justifiées ainsi
qu'à faire respecter les règles de port
du masque d'interdiction des
regroupements et de restrictions de
circulation des personnes
en visite dans un hôpital de dunkerque
le ministre de la santé a également
promis une accélération du plan de
vaccination 16700 doses supplémentaires
doivent être envoyés dans la région
fin janvier le centre hospitalier de la
ville avait dû repousser le lancement de
sa campagne faute de vaccins et à partir
de demain leur dire orford il ya tous
les médecins généralistes qui peuvent
commencer à vacciner leurs patients
et dans quelques jours ça va être lancée
en des termes assez servier des médecins
qui commence à vacciner on fait partir
ce qui nous manque a précédé doses je
regarde le ciel pour pas du ciel on est
content mais des plus honorables visera
un confinement et pas de dernière chance
donc pour les élus qui ont tout tenté
pour éviter ce scénario
certains sont en colère face à la
lenteur du gouvernement malgré leur
appel à agir
la cavalerie arrive trois semaines en
retard avec sa trompette
ce jeudi jean castex et olivier véran
doivent tenir un nouveau point presse de
nouvelles restrictions locales
pourraient être annoncés alors qu
emmanuel macron a appelé à une
régionalisation des réponses à la crise
sanitaire
outre le nord et les alpes-maritimes
l'ile-de-france est la région grand-est
suscite l'inquiétude et seront
particulièrement surveillées